in which continent is the Himalaya
Mountain Range Alaska Asia I'd hate to
be the geography teacher for any of
these streamers India is this one let's
try it that's India that's India Somali
yo somebody in my chat tell me what kind
of country it is what country is
this
[Music]
what
okay right okay so it's
we're in Canada China is this one that's
Russia
French Poland and then the other one
[Music]
Spain's not all the way on the west I
think that's France and Portugal these
two so Spain should be over here you
know or like here that's Germany I can
actually uh name you guys all
seven
continents okay
um United States
the islands Canada oh
foreign